Pat we are starting to see sort of the
Russian matryoshka doll equivalent of
people lowering up now Donald Trump's
lawyer has lawyer duck the investigation
into Donald Trump and Russia is clearly
getting closer and closer to more and
more Donald Trump associates previously
I told you that Donald Trump personally
lawyered up at the recommendation of his
lawyer Michael Cohen so Michael Cohen
went to Donald Trump and said you should
get a lawyer specifically for the Russia
stuff so Donald Trump hired mark caso
it's to represent him personally in the
Trump Russia thing we now know that
Trump is personally under investigation
by special prosecutor Robert Moeller
now Donald Trump's lawyer Michael Cohen
has lawyered up himself and recall that
Michael Cohen plays in the entire
Russian blackmail dossier Michael Cohen
is one of the people supposedly involved
in hand-delivering that plan related to
the easing of Russian sanctions
involving disgraced former national
security adviser Michael Flynn so he has
hired a lawyer as it appears to be
closing in on him as well he will be
represented by Washington DC attorney
Stephen Ryan and a source told NBC's
Katy tour that Michael Cohen will
testify before the House Intelligence
Committee on September 5th now you might
say wow that's that's really a long time
from now
apparently the testimony was delayed due
to quote scheduling and logistics but it
is not just Michael Cohen who is luring
up Vice President Mike Pence is also
lowering up and that is yet another
indication that this is closing in he's
hired personal representation Richard :
an attorney who previously served as US
attorney in the Eastern District of
Virginia is representing vice president
Mike Pence on everything related to the
two congressional investigations as well
as Robert molars special prosecutor
investigation this is not good everybody
seems to have to lawyer up at this point
well first off it would make sense that
Michael Cohen would want to lawyer up
because he's been Donald Trump's
personal lawyer for ten years now
yeah it's not he's just signed on since
the Russia probes began sure and if you
look at the Christopher Steele dossier
that dossier alleges that he met with
Russian agents in Prague short to
discuss a potential cover-up of the
hacks yes so he's heavily involved and
of course he denied having ever gone to
Prague reseting then walked the land in
Prague was an early type answer yeah
when we looked at the letter of that he
said he never walked the land of Prague
which means hey if he was in an airport
without having cleared customs for
example was he technically walking the
land in Prague not really the does just
one hypothetical right but what's the
what's the silver lining here I'm now
doing the Pat Forde thing where I'm
trying to find silver linings Trump is
finally creating work because there's a
bunch of lawyers now that are doing
really well representing different
people associated with Trump with
relation to the Trump Russia situation
Trump's lawyer has a lawyer
it's lawyers all the way down a
reference to the unmoved mover paradox
look that up it's interesting it Turtles
all the way down is the phrase as it
originally is but I think a better
analogy Pat if you'll allow me is since
we're dealing with Russia
these are those Russian matryoshka dolls
successively smaller and smaller dolls
nested within each other its successive
representation by lawyers nested within
each other is what we're seeing here I
like that and then my comparison would
be to house of cards because it would
make sense that Mike Pence would want to
lawyer up as well because if Trump was
to be impeached then he would have to
keep his own name clear to assume the
presidency that's what I'm most
interested in which is Mike Pence's
involvement what did he know and when he
was after all the head of the transition
team he ignored multiple warnings about
Michael Flynn he generally lies a lot
like most of the people associated with
Donald Trump I wouldn't be shocked if
Mike Pence turns his back on Trump if it
all starts closing in on him I have no
idea what was going on I was brought in
as a running mate
they kept me out of the loop I didn't
know what was happening bla bla bla and
by the way another lawyer speaking of
Russian dolls Mark Kassovitz has told
some White House personnel they don't
need to hire their own lawyers and now
you
is potentially in trouble with multiple
State Bar Association's for that
recommendation mark Kassovitz
Trump's personal lawyer facing ethics
complaints because he told White House
staffers don't worry you don't need to
hire lawyers this is really building
into a show of incompetence building on
arrogance and pomposity sprinkled with
delusions of grandeur and hypocrisy
well I'm sure being the president and
vice president Trump and pence will be
able to get the best lawyers in the
country right the cream of the crop
let's dig into that now that is the next
thing I want to talk about